welcome back to las vegas now no matter
where you are in the world it is
important to protect your skin from the
sun especially right here in the desert
and around healthcare the sponsors of
this next segment they explain
[Music]
i'm dr shmael bhatt and i'm a medical
oncologist with intermountain healthcare
and today we're going to talk about some
complications caused by sunlight and how
to prevent from those complications
sunlight has ultraviolet radiations
which increase the risk of skin sunburn
skin aging and can predispose to
skin cancers in the long run so whenever
you're planning to go out in the sun
make sure you slide on your sunglasses
slap on your broad brim hat
slip on your clothes
slop on your sunscreen
and seek for the shade whenever possible
uv index is a marker of the strength of
the ultraviolet radiations in the
sunlight and those radiations are
maximum
between 10 am and 4 pm so whenever
you're planning to go out in the sun
make sure you watch for the forecast for
uv index and studies have shown that
when the uv index is more than three
there's increased risk of complications
from sunlight ultraviolet radiations in
sunlight increase the risk of skin
cancer so whenever you're looking at a
mole on your skin always watch for any
changes so for example if there is
asymmetry
if the borders are irregular color is
changing surface is irregular size is
increasing watch for those changes in a
mode also when there is non-healing
ulcer or any
non-healing lumps or bums on your skin
always consult with your physicians to
make sure that it's not a cancer
broad-spectrum sunscreens reduce the
risk of skin cancer by 50
so
whenever you're thinking applying a
sunscreen make sure sunscreen is broad
spectrum what it means that it should
prevent against both ultraviolet a and
ultraviolet b radiations it should be
water and sweat resistant and at least
spf 30 or above as a general rule
whenever your skin is exposed to
sunlight you should apply sunscreen so
really doesn't matter you're outside or
inside
windows do not prevent all the
ultraviolet radiations falling on your
skin so whenever you are being exposed
to sunlight always apply sunscreen
a lot of my patients ask
do sunburns lead to skin cancer and my
answer to them is yes sunburns increase
the risk of skin cancer in the future
by as much as twice but also i tell them
you know you don't have to have sunburn
to increase the risk of skin cancer
sunlight increase the risk of skin
cancers even without causing sunburn so
always make sure you protect your skin
from the side effects of sunlight always
use your precautions that we just
discussed also if you have ever
have any kind of concern about any
abnormal spots in your skin we are here
to help you out
thank you to in around healthcare for
sponsoring that segment head to
intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada for more information earlier we
heard about